[Music]
location data brings some of the most
useful and rich and amazing experiences
to users on mobile devices things like
turn-by-turn directions when was the
last time you pulled out a paper map to
figure out how to get from point A to
point B and if a road was closed
rerouting was pulling over to recon sult
your paper map or worst yet having to
actually talk to somebody to ask for
directions next recording the distance
of a hike or a run or a bicycle ride
it's never been easier to map your route
or monitor your progress whether you're
just a casual runner or training for
something specific and of course
discovering new restaurants and places
of interest it's become so easy to find
the best places to eat to drink to
sightsee and of course most importantly
the best places to take selfies now you
can get reviews and recommendations from
thousands of other users instead of just
consulting the people that you know or
buying a guide which gets obsolete over
time however location data is also some
of our most personal information as you
heard in our keynote yesterday privacy
and security have been an important part
of Android since the beginning and it is
a core part of Android q an Android q we
extend transparency and control to users
for their location data next Praveen and
Wei are going to dive into the details
but let me start with two driving
principles that grounded how we thought
about these changes as a user you want
to be in control of your data and you
only want to share location with apps
when it makes sense we want to provide
simple discoverable and
easy-to-understand controls to users so
they know what apps have access to their
location and whether it's on or off well
talk in the session about how we're
bringing more control to users about
when apps can access their location
second we want users to have
transparency over what apps have access
to their location especially when it
might be unexpected we'll also talk
about how we're providing helpful
reminders to users about when apps are
accessing their location when in the
background so they can determine whether
they want to continue that or not next
I'll hand it to Praveen to get us
started Thanks hey everyone very good
morning to all of you and thanks for
joining us today
I'm from in Chandran I'm a product
manager in the Android location services
team as Jen said we would like to
provide simple discoverable
easy-to-understand controls for users to
be able to control access to location
data users only want to share sensitive
data like location with apps when it
makes sense so in Android queue we have
added the ability for users to control
which apps can access their device
location when they're not using the app
now before Android q location permission
was really a binary choice in that a
user could either allow or deny access
to their device location if we user
provided location permission to an app
the app could get access to the user's
device location when the user was using
the app but also when the user was not
using the app in Android q we have
introduced a new location permission
allow only while using the app if a user
chooses this option the app would be
able to get access to the user's device
location only when the user is using the
app for this new permission how do we
define when the app is in use well there
are two scenarios for this permission an
app is considered to be in use when the
user is looking at the app on their
device screen which
commonly known as a foreground activity
or when the app is running a foreground
service what's a good example of a
foreground service let us say you're
using a navigation app and you have
requested turn-by-turn directions from
the app while the app is providing
turn-by-turn directions if you hit on
the home button to get to the home
screen or you turn on the device screen
altogether you would notice that the
navigation app would continue to provide
directions even when you are on the home
screen now that's a good example of an
app using a foreground service now for
the rest of this presentation whenever
we refer to an app being in use or when
we say an app is in the foreground we
are referring to foreground activity or
foreground service and every other type
of activity is considered to be
background activity in a few minutes
I'll talk about some changes in queue
related to getting location when running
a foreground service but before I talk
about that let me tell a little bit more
into the details of this new permission
to get location permission you need to
declare access fine location or access
course location in the manifest
typically course location is at the city
level while fine location is as best as
we can do before Android cue if you had
specified access fine location or access
course location and the manifest your
app could get location in the foreground
and in the background in Android cue if
your app is targeting cue SDK you should
add a declaration for access background
location and the manifest if your app
needs to access the user's device
location in the background because your
current declaration of access fine
location or access course location will
only let your app access the device
location when the app is of the
foreground however if your app is
targeting pre q SDK your existing
declaration of access fine location or
access course location would
automatically be mapped to access
background location and there really is
no way for apps to opt-out off this
automatic mapping now one of the key
benefits of targeting q SDK is that if
your app needs location permission only
when the app is in the foreground you
can choose to request only this location
permission from the user and get
location when the app is in use in other
words you can choose not to request
location permission when the app is not
in use or rather the app is in the
background as a best practice we highly
recommend developers to utilize this
capability and always ask only for the
permission needed for the app another
key benefit of targeting q SDK is that
your app can now make incremental
location permission requests and
incremental permission requests are
incredibly helpful in presenting the
location permission dialog whenever the
user accesses the feature gain as the
best practice we recommend developers to
show the permission dialog when the user
accesses the relevant feature so that
the user can understand why an app is
asking for a certain permission or even
for a certain level of permission let us
say your app needs to access location in
the foreground or in the band or in the
background users are much more likely to
grant the level of access needed for
your app when users are requested to
evaluate these permissions requests
separately and at the time they are
accessing the relevant feature let's
take this example of my train commute
app which helps users manage their train
commute this app would provide the train
schedule of a nearby train station based
on the user's location when the user is
looking at the app and this app would
send
in communications when the user is not
actively looking at the app based on the
users background location now for this
app when the user opens the app for the
first time and the user wants to access
train schedule at that time the app can
show the dialog that you see on the
screen requesting only while in use
permission and the user is likely to
understand why the app is asking for
this permission saying yeah I get it you
know in order to get the train schedule
of a nearby station this app needs to
know my location now and the user would
be much more likely to provide this
permission let us say the user has
provided this permission then the user
looks around the app reaches the Train
commute notifications feature wants to
opt in to Train commute notifications at
that point in time the app can show the
permission dialog that you see here
requesting the user to provide the
higher level of access which is the
ability to access device location all
the time
if the dialog is presented at that time
the user would think in order to send
the notification this app needs to
access my location in the background I
get it
so I'll provide this level of access as
you can see from the dialog in the
incremental permission request the user
would have two options either to allow
the app to access the device location
all the time or to say keep the current
level of access I don't want to provide
the higher level of access now the first
request permission to access device
location only in the foreground you can
specify access course location or access
file location in the request permissions
method and if the user allows your app
would be able to access device location
in the foreground how do you request
users for a higher level of access or
rather the ability to access device
location in the background as the best
practice we recommend developers to
first check if your app has access to
device location in the foreground and if
it does
you can specify access background
location in the request permissions
method to request a user for this higher
level of access on that note how do you
know if your app has access to device
location in the foreground and or in the
background you can use the checked self
permission method to see if your app has
been granted access fine location or
access course location permission and if
it has been granted your app can access
the user's device location in the
foreground you can use the same method
to check if the app has access
background location permission granted
and if it has been granted your app can
now access the user's device location in
the background a key aspect to think
about what this new permission is what
is the impact of this new location
permission based on the SDK version
targeted by your app users will be able
to set while in use permission for apps
requesting location permission in
Android cue users could go to settings
and change the permission of your app
from all the time to wall in news what
does that mean for your app if your app
is targeting P SDK or lower your app
could get into situation where your app
is expecting location updates in the
background but the user would have
changed the location permission for your
app to wallet news at that point in time
your app cannot get location updates in
the background due to which some
features that are dependent on
background location may not work as
intended we highly suggest developers to
handle the situation graciously and make
sure the features that are dependent on
background location would you know
provide the right messaging to the user
letting them know that the app doesn't
have this level of access or make sure
the features continue to work as
intended
even without background location we also
highly recommend developers to test an
upgrade to qsd
as early as possible now for this new
permission another key aspect to think
about is what would happen to the
location permission of apps when a user
upgrades their device from Android PI to
Android Q well the apps which had
location permission in Android PI would
continue to retain the permissions even
after the device upgrade in other words
if an app had location permission in
Android Pi the app would be able to
access the users device location in the
foreground and in the background even
after the device upgrade we chose to
retain location permissions for apps on
OS upgrade so that the user experiences
do not break and the apps or the
features in the apps continue to work as
intended
a few slides back we talked about when
an app is considered to be in use and at
that point I'm at said we'll talk a
little bit more about foreground
services in queue we are introducing
some changes to how apps can get device
location when they are running a
foreground service but before we talk
about the change let's for a moment
understand the need for accessing
location went running a foreground
service when using an app the user might
use a feature that requires the app to
access their device location even after
the user gets to the home screen by
hitting the home button or if the user
turns off the device screen a good
example again would be the navigation
app that we spoke about a few minutes
ago now in the navigation app if you
remember the user initiated an action in
the app requesting the app to provide
turn-by-turn directions and while the
app was providing the turn-by-turn
directions the user had the home button
to get to the home screen in such cases
the app should continue the action
initiated by the user and continue to
get location to provide turn-by-turn
directions in this example the app would
use a foreground service and needs to
access location went running a for
answer
typically whenever an app needs to
continue an action initiated by the user
in the app the app would need to use a
foreground service now users expect this
type of navigation to work even if the
app only has volunteers access so to be
in line with the users expectations the
apps need to use foreground service and
need to continue to get location went
running a foreground service now what's
new in queue is that apps which need to
get location when running a 4-run
service need to declare foreground
service of type location in the manifest
we will be limiting permission usage
based on this type of declaration you
can declare foreground service of type
location using the foreground service
type attribute in this service element
of the manifest file if you do not
declare foreground service of type
location and if the user has provided
only while enews permission to your app
your app cannot get location when
running a foreground service if an app
has all the time access though it can
get location when running a full-blown
service even without this declaration
and the manifest if an app specifies
foreground service of type location in
the manifest the app has to compile
against the cue SDK version now this
changes for all apps irrespective of the
target SDK version in other words apps
need to declare foreground service of
type location in the manifest if the app
wants to access location when running a
foreground service and the APIs either
only requested valley new's permission
or the user has only provided wiling us
permission to the app on that note there
was a talk on adapting your apps for
Android queue privacy requirements I
think it was at 8:30 today morning the
talk was given by Charmaine and sweat
one of the aspects that was discussed in
that presentation was the different
types of foreground service in the stock
I covered foreign service of type
location if you would like to know about
the other types of foreground service I
highly recommend you should check out
that talk on YouTube later now at the
beginning of the session Jen talked
about providing more visibility to the
user on apps accessing the user's device
location as a way to bring more
transparency and visibility to users in
android q we are introducing location
reminder notifications location
information is sensitive and users share
sensitive data alike location when it
makes sense but occasionally users could
forget the level of location permission
given to apps especially the less
frequently used apps so we are going to
gently nudge the user with a
notification if the app accesses their
device location when the user is not
actively using the app here is an
example of what that notification would
look like in android q in this case the
might rain commute app has accessed the
user's location when the app was not
being used so the user gets his
notification and the notification lets
the user know that this app can access
their device location all the time at
that point when the user taps on the
notification the user will be directed
to the location permission page of the
app where the user could make a decision
on the right level of access for the app
and can even choose to change the
permission to while in use or deny when
does the user get this notification the
user will get a one time poor app
notification when the user provides all
the time location permission to an app
and the app receives fine location
update in the background
to add a bit more context if the user
has provided all the time access changes
it to while in use or deny and then
eventually in the future again revert
sit back to all the time the user might
see the notification again till now I
have covered the features in Android
queue intent and to provide more
visibility and control to users on apps
accessing their device location I now
request way to come up on stage to talk
about location permission considerations
for Wi-Fi api's thanks for it good
morning everyone my name is we one I'm a
software engineer in Android location
team proven talking about more control
and better readability of Direction
location access through location service
advised in Android queue
however Android it's possible to get
indirection location size from
connectivity api's especially by eyes
and we all know Wi-Fi connectivity is
critical on mobile devices
as Wi-Fi devices become ubiquitous
people connect to Wi-Fi almost all the
time that connect to Wi-Fi access points
to go to the internet and connect to
local Wi-Fi devices for peer-to-peer
file transfer all managing IOT devices
applications sometimes want to have
users to connect to Wi-Fi devices before
q Android provides api's for Wi-Fi
connectivity applications typically do a
Wi-Fi scan first to get a list of nearby
Wi-Fi networks and choose which what I
device to connect you knowingly nearby
Wi-Fi devices makes it possible to
derive the device location so this IP is
are protected by location permission
this call is a lot of confusions to
users and they just want to use F for
Wi-Fi connectivity and do not understand
why they have requested location
permission so to solve this problem
angle Q we're introducing two new Wi-Fi
api's Wi-Fi network suggestion and Wi-Fi
network specified you didn't listen guys
the application can tell the Wi-Fi
system what was my devices they want to
connect you and the Wi-Fi system will do
the scan and decide whether to connect
to those devices when they are in range
the key difference from the prequel IV
is using new IP is the application will
not get access to the nearby Wi-Fi
device information so the application
does not need to request location
permission for the mall to better
provide to better protect user privacy
on q all the Wi-Fi a few guys that have
location information will be protected
by final location permission so we
highly recommend using the new api's for
Wi-Fi connectivity to avoid requesting
location permission in your application
let's take a deeper look at this advice
the first guy I want to talk about is
Wi-Fi network suggestion one of the
major the case for Wi-Fi connectivity is
to connect the mobile device to the
Internet so users can browse the web
with others somewhat vacations might
know certain networks the user can
connect you when I go to airports
libraries or coffee shops thank you
such apps can use the Wi-Fi network
suggesting api's to recommend those
networks to the Wi-Fi system let's look
at an example a local coffee shop wants
to provide Wi-Fi internet to his
customers when a new stop the ones who
recommended the Wi-Fi network to the
device through their card my coffee shop
so users can connect automatically when
they enter the style and let's see how
it works
so first the F needs to tear the once a
system what network to connect you
this is done by setting into the SSID LP
SSID in the Wi-Fi network situation
object also the as need to tell one her
system how to connect to these networks
so if any credentials are needed for the
Wi-Fi connection the F also need to
provide that in a Wi-Fi network
situation object after that you can
simply call as Network suggestions to
add this suggestion to us a manager so
we only use one network suggestion an
example here but in practice the
commission or multiple different Wi-Fi
networks and the app can add a list of
those suggestions after these
suggestions are successfully added once
I system will be able to use these
suggestions for connection once the
Wi-Fi system detects the network
suggested by the app and nearby and
these apps are based for Wi-Fi internet
connectivity at that moment it will show
a notification to let users know that a
network suggested by my coffee shop F in
is available for connection and request
approval from the user after user
approves the suggestion next time
the water system will auto connect to
the two networks suggested by the same F
if these networks are the best for
connectivity at that moment so the micro
shop app only provides the suggestions
it cannot get access to nearby Wi-Fi
device information and it does not know
that the suggestion network has been
connected so it has no location access
and the and the app does not need to
request location permission
occasionally application may want to
know that the suggestion network has
been connected for instance the coffee
shop may request user login before using
their network and my coffee shop app
want to login euros automatically after
the connection ended up with European
users to accept in photo so Wi-Fi
networks Edition provides the
credibility for this purpose however
since the F knows the location of the
Wi-Fi network knowing the connection has
been established makes it possible for
the application to derive the device
location so this app will now request a
location permission similar with the
previous example create a Wi-Fi network
suggestion object with the SSID and a
credential for the access point the key
here is set is app in action required to
indicate the application wants to be
notified when the device has connected
to the suggestion network next register
broadcast receiver to listen to Wi-Fi
network suggestion post the connection
broadcast this broadcast is sent to the
application when the network suggested
by the app is connected and I've just
said knowing the connection makes it
possible to derive the device location
so the broadcast is only sent to
applications if it has been grown here
with access fine location permission so
we recommend using this capability only
when you have a very strong user case of
doing so all right so that's the
networks additional guide for suggesting
access points for Internet connectivity
another lucky look as for Wi-Fi
connectivity is connect to a local Wi-Fi
device for peer-to-peer Wi-Fi
connectivity for instance users might
take photos with action cameras when I
go skiing and would like to transfer
those photos to the mobile phones like
how oh let me help us much too much that
they want to stat have using the app on
their phone for you look at like this we
introduced a new Wi-Fi network specify
API in queue so here we got an IOT
device that means something you should
set up it has no UI so you might need to
plug this into a computer for setup Oh
more easily you didn't know why find
that we can specify API you can put just
power of the device connect this to your
mobile phone through Wi-Fi and to ascend
hub from application running on the
phone the elf will need to specify the
SSID or bssid pattern to match the IOT
device the phone can do the scans for
the Wi-Fi device is matching this
purpose and once I'm matching Wi-Fi
device is found the system will pop up a
dialog requesting users to connect and
select which device to connect to the
system will remember your choice and
auto connect to the same device
previously approved by the user similar
with Wi-Fi networks edition API the
application can have access to the
nearby Wi-Fi information so local
permission so the current permission is
not needed now let's take a look at how
to use this API first you need to create
a Wi-Fi network specifier and specify
how you find the pure devices you can
either say the SSID pattern obvious as I
paid him as a regular connection to
match the Wi-Fi devices you want to find
next create a number of Christ's using
the network specify so the purpose of
Wi-Fi network specify is for
peer-to-peer Wi-Fi connection instead of
Internet
connectivity so so it's required to
remove the Internet connectivity from
the network request once network request
is created you can use the Europe
connectivity manager guys to request
connecting to the network other type we
just talked about two new Wi-Fi api's
for connectivity without location access
Wi-Fi network a suggestion and Wi-Fi
network specified this API provides the
capability fabrications to suggest
access points I'll connect local Wi-Fi
devices application using this advice
don't have access to nearby Wi-Fi
devices so no location permission is
needed
we recommend using this advice for Wi-Fi
connectivity perverse going forward
especially applications targeting Hill
SDK wouldn't be able to use the pre Q
advice to auto connect to a previously
config access point or config new save
the network
so this apps will need to migrate to the
new edge guys and also as I previously
mentioned all the Wi-Fi edges the heavy
location information will need access
fine location permission thank you
with that Jen will come back to talk
about best practices for you know
location
thanks way now that we've talked to how
to update your apps for some of the new
changes in Android Q I'm going to
summarize by talking through some of the
best practices first don't use location
data if you don't need it as we just
talked about any API that provides
location related information will
require the location permission however
these new Wi-Fi suggestion and
peer-to-peer api's allow you to
implement connectivity use cases without
using location information and so if
your app supports these types of use
cases we encourage you to migrate to use
these new api's this will also make the
experience simpler for your users only
ask for the permission that you need one
of the key benefits to the while and use
permission is you can ask for that if
that's the only permission that you need
don't ask for all the time permission if
all you need is one use this also makes
the decision simpler and more
straightforward for users also as we
mentioned and the manifest you can
declare either coarse or fine location
permission as Praveen mentioned course
is approximately city level and there's
some use cases such as weather that work
fine with just coarse location so
encourage you to evaluate all the
features within your app and decide if
you really need fine location next ask
the user for location permission in
context we suggest surfacing the
location permission prompt when the user
interacts with or turns on a specific
feature in your app that requires it
this also helps the user understand why
your application is asking we don't
recommend surfing's in the permission
prompt on app startup unless it's
absolutely obvious to the user why for
consider an incremental request as
Praveen had mentioned you can ask for a
while and use permission first when the
users interacting with your app and then
later ask for all the time permission
when the user specifically turning on a
feature that requires it
and finally gracefully handle all levels
of location permission as always users
can change the location permission for
any app at any time we encourage you to
gracefully handle when your app doesn't
have background location or any location
we also recommend that non location
features within your app continue to
work even if you don't have location
permission thank you for creating all
these amazing location-based experiences
for our users we can do so much more
today than we ever thought possible and
together we can create new innovative
experiences while keeping our users and
their data safe we hope the information
that we've provided to you today is
helpful in updating your apps to Android
q a quick reminder that we have office
hours later today at 11:30 and again
tomorrow morning at 8:30 a.m. there's
also a code lab on location that you can
try out
[Music]